ils étaient plusieurs centaines massés
devant le cercueil de georges floyd pour
lui rendre un dernier hommage
cet homme afro américains tués lors de
son interpellation par la police a été
inhumé à houston la ville où elle a
grandi
une cérémonie de plus de trois heures
lors de laquelle des messages politiques
se sont mêlés aux larmes
si quatre policiers noirs avaient fait
un homme blanc ce qui a été fait à
georges il n'y aurait pas besoin d'en
tirer des leçons qu'il n'aurait pas
besoin de convaincre les grandes
entreprises de donner de l'argent
il les aurait envoyés en prison et tant
que nous n'aurons pas compris qu'une vie
noir coûte le même prix qu'une vie
blanche
nous allons continuer à nous retrouver
confrontés à des situations comme celle
ci encore et encore
les proches du défunt ou eux salué celui
qui est surnommé big georges leurs douze
géants ou encore superman la mort de
georges floyd a provoqué une
mobilisation inédite aux états unis et
les appelle à lutter contre les
inégalités raciales ont gagné le monde
entier comme s'en félicite l'avocat de
la famille
il ne s'agissait pas seulement de just
fly de l'inhumer avec respect il
s'agissait des générations futures pour
qu'elles sachent que d'orge était une
personne comme chacun d'entre nous et
que si on fait ça à l'un d'entre nous
cela nous affecte tous c'est le message
aujourd'hui
pas un mot de la part de donald trump à
l'occasion de cette cérémonie il a au
contraire mis en cause la responsabilité
d'un homme de 75 ans poussé par des
policiers lors d'une manifestation
son rival à la présidentielle de 2000
d'un joe biden s'est lui exprimé dans
une vidéo diffusée lors des obsèques
aujourd'hui c'est un moment où il est
nécessaire de prendre le temps d'écouter
et de réconcilier leurs de la justice
raciale est venu c'est la réponse que
nous devons donner à nos enfants lorsqu
ils nous demandent pourquoi parce que
lorsque justice sera rendue pour georges
floyd nous serons vraiment sur la voie
de la justice raciale en amérique
et alors comme tu l'as dit diana de ton
papa aura changé le monde
un père de famille devenu un symbole
mondial des violences policières et
racistes dans le pays
partout dans le monde la mobilisation se
poursuit
des milliers de manifestants ont défilé
hier réclamant l'égalité pour les
minorités ethniques et la fin des
violences policières